mouloud c'est le film de woods qu'on
attendait depuis très longtemps et
mouloud il voudrait dire voilà il a un
talent exceptionnel je sais que vous
avez qui fait le film s'il ya par
isabelle qui n'a pas tout compris
sinon pour ceux qui sont encore là ainsi
présents pour cette société ils ont
adoré et j'aurai une très belle surprise
pour toi dans un instant une vraie
surprise ton idole ok je sais que tu as
vous a demandé qui vous aimeriez
rencontrer voilà eh bien tu as choisi et
tu va le rencontrer en grèce a réussi à
me l'avoir c'est une star internationale
c'est une surprise mais je te dis pas
une star internationale mais non oui
plus inter que
[Applaudissements]
romane frayssinette avec nos impôts ni
sans parler
merci
dessiner hakim géminides a franchement
les mecs
tellement content de pouvoir tu me fais
tellement je suis très heureux d'être là
ça fait plaisir on vous dit adorer
requis motivation c'est
un casting merci tu as pris les gâte le
moment il ya deux jumeaux qui est avec
nous
et
là vous vous dites oui il a travaillé sa
tenue depuis hier pour me dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cependant tout de suite des méchants et
après tu vas disant parler bien entendu
on va faire plein de trucs ensemble je
sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai envie de
tout casser 60 dans tous les sens et
j'ai envie de faire une grande lande
enfants
[Applaudissements]
et
10 mo j'adore ta
ttc ont dit avoir dans mon salon
regardez je kiffe de regarder mais non
le trouve bon bah t'as qu'à pas
amel et soler solaire
soit un soleil tape exciteront avec ça
[Applaudissements]
tu vas rester habillé comme ça pour
l'heure il est plus simple et belle
pièce el atter certaines blagues
sans rien dire et mercedes et jeanine
merci c'est
ouais mais c'est super méchant c'était
en fous toi bien un truc entre que chan
pas je dégage quelque chose de malsain
une heure et en exclusivité sur ce
plateau carcéral martin
caceres et 13 10 le platine et 13
condamnations
il vient d'y avoir en direct sur votre
télé un attentat envers 91 glissement
j'allume la télé pour garder ma série on
cela qu'il ya les méchants la 2 il ya
les méchants et des vidéos de nous
partout à la télé sur internet ils
disent qu'on est les méchants et qu'on
veut faire sauter la plaine bourse
je suis déjà
très bien se passer
dans la peur de la baule et vas-y ta
gueule avec ta tête de puceau ce que je
peux vous poser une question qu'est ce
qu'ils ont acheté exactement un jus
antioxydants antioxydantes non mais
comme ne commençons pas accuser les gens
sur deux motos mauvais jeu de mots
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est
comme aller chez pas une idée de du lot
j'ai eu l'idée d'en c'est un moment un
peu grave en fait j'habitais juste à
côté du bataclan et il ya eu les
attentats de charlie il ya eu le
bataclan il ya unissent et et moi je
faisais partie des gens qui étaient
allés manifester à ce moment là toi
d'ailleurs on était tous réunis et au
bout de quelques temps au moment où on
devait tous faire corps et mon et qu' il
fallait contrer le projet de véro et
s'est divisé la société française les
attentats on a commencé nous mêmes a
exclu une certaine communauté du roman
national en disant que les musulmans il
fallait qu'ils se désolidarisent où
c'était pas des français pour les comme
les autres et on m'avait invité dans une
chaîne info du groupe tf1 moi j'étais
par les voilà
[Rires]
parce que quand je vais dans le groupe
des réformes parle du groupe canal donc
t'inquiète pas c'est lci t'inquiète pas
ici on parlera du aucun groupe
abase un très bon groupe a rien à carrer
est en fait moi je pensais que j'en ai
parlé de clic de kanye west de notre
travail on arrête tout de suite orientée
sur les attentats j'ai trouvé ça super
violent super triste et moi j'ai un truc
c'est que j'aime bien rire des trucs
triste et tu dis qu'il fallait en même
temps qu'on soit capable d'enseigner
d'intelligent le film c'est tout le
monde est divisé où tout le monde est en
train de s'engueuler partout de se dire
venez on rit ensemble non pas les uns
des autres mais les uns avec les autres
et je voulais réunir la france dans une
salle ivre et nombreux en fait le titre
nrj
c'est vrai que c'est c'est le mot qui me
l'a fait pour les méchants c'est bon je
vous dis raconte l'histoire c'est au ban
donc sébastien qui tombe qui a volé une
console de jeux vidéo qui tentent de la
revendre à patrick donc dit mot mais un
rapport tout juste sortie de prison une
journaliste d'une chaîne info prête à
tout pour faire le buzz s'en mêle et
tout dérape c'est exactement ce qui pose
pas selon lui parce qu on en rigole lui
c'est vrai tu te dis que moi c'est pas
loin de là réalise est arrivé sur ton
plateau quand il ya eu le pauvre
restaurateurs
où il ya eu un fou qu'a eu des insultes
négrophobe on verra bien sûr on va vers
une dame exactement à lui en fait il a
été désigné méchant sur les réseaux
sociaux et personne n'a voulu écouter la
vérité venu ici le pauvre il a vécu des
moments je te dis au
delà de du plateau ils ont vécu trois
jours vraiment de gauche en bas rhin et
jusqu'à ce qu'on se rende compte que
c'était pas lui du tout c'est vrai que
quand on est allé chercher samedi à ce
que sa famille samedi leur nom voire et
sami je voudrais dire c'est jean paul
belmondo nous a quittés hier et jean
paul disait de samy c'était un des plus
grands acteurs français si ce n'est le
plus talentueux et c'est vrai et ça nous
a fait très plaisir d'en voir sami qui
est extraordinaire samy naceri colle
parfaitement aux discours des méchants
samu c'est quelqu'un qui a payé sa dette
qui a fait des erreurs qui est qu'on a
toujours considéré comme méchant alors
qu'il a un prix d'interprétation à
cannes que c'est un des plus grands
acteurs français qu'il a porté une voix
qui n'existait pas depuis rail que c'est
un des acteurs les plus populaires avec
taxi et que moi quand j'étais petit et
que variées samy naceri je voyais des
gens de ma famille qui nous ressemblait
au cinéma et j'avais envie d'avoir un
immense acteur dans mon film et merci
beaucoup
ou tu es yaro match mal et franchement
romane se promènent j'ai écrit le film
pour lui en fait ouais quand qu'entre
mal est arrivé dans les bureaux de kick
j'ai eu un coût d'un coup de foudre j'ai
rien vu de lui je lui dis tu commence
dimanche et un an après pour son
anniversaire j'ai offert le scénario et
j'ai pas compris la praire fois que j'ai
lu non certes mais c'est mon lucho
obligé et m'a trouvé je parlais tout
seul dans le métro
[Rires]
mais je voudrais dire quelque chose sur
robben les satyres très rare dans le
métier c'est un mec d'une fidélité que
mouloud exceptionnel parce que je peux
dire croisade il a dit il ya des
propositions tout le temps vraiment de
partout vraiment c'est un truc de fou ce
qui se passe autour de danser comme
acquis minerai aussi c'est vraiment des
mecs voilà et c'est ça que j'aime dans
cette nouvelle génération aussi c'est
des mecs [ __ ] tu dis qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont droit hibou voilà isma pression du
tt d'une fidélité incroyable ça je
voulais te le dire pas à la base on a
fait ça pour traîner avec des as mais
pour rigoler avec mollo jay
l'impressionnante avec un as mais je
rigole et c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse
a pas remarqué que de plus en plus des
amis en ce moment mais c'est vrai
je suis devenu mignon j'ai réalisé mes
moyens
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai parce qu'à chaque fois qu'il
ya un club qui veut que je revienne dans
une forêt mais [ __ ] t'es convient il y
aura romane seyfried et précis né il ya
kim gemini
ils sont dans toutes les régions et les
mecs en fait et les mecs veulent
absolument être copain avec vous un
crime c'est pareil cas aussi ouais mais
bon je suis pas fidèle
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis ultra fine à tu me connais je
sais mais ce qui est dingue c'est tout à
l'heure il y aura et christian clavier
moi j'ai l'impression que toute cette
bande là quand on regarde la fiche ouais
c'est ça c'est la nouvelle bande du
splendid ont fait exactement sauf que
c'est des vrais bronzés c'est vrai nom
mais
et et jimoh aussi vraiment dix mois en
fait toi t'en sers le web mais comme
c'est vrai je kiffe idée lui
extraordinaire de chefs étoilés
pas dû redonner de l'est de l'île de les
tenir sont ils sont ils sont sache au
plateau tout ça c'est plutôt eux le dire
mais je suis un peu un dictateur mois
sur leur trio oui ça faut des gens d'un
costume particulier quand il vient très
bonne offre
spéciale un tee shirt il est dans un
personnage
dispose comme ça il fait des fautes mais
je ne sais jamais si comme ça
d'aller contre la volonté de sa personne
je sais pas de même parce que moi je ne
vois pas du tout venir non mais c'est
très bien ce qu'il veut croire c'est ça
c'est bien ça ça fait plaisir tu vas lui
sait où aller c'est une bombe
franchement c'est un c'est un génie
merci c'est vrai que c'est vrai c'est un
génie et mettrait bnr massages je suis
allé une fois chez lui un dimanche soir
il voulait faire un jacuzzi avec moi je
dis nous restons
adapté qui voulait tester jeudi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
jeudi à mouloud et on se voit il manie
pas chez moi dimanche soir
gimont apparaît chez refusé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça s'est passé tu connaisses et
mouloud ou pas du tout évidemment tu le
connaissais bien que vous étiez pas tous
bien joué j'avais 25 ans que les mouloud
et alors tu at heart out as tu accepté
tout mais bien évidemment que quand nous
lonshi arrivée dans le bureau il était
avec dominique beau marais qui réalise
avec lui et pour udine du baiia de rôle
iliad suis là j'aimerais bien que tu
fasses leu leu l'agent de verser
l'argent déversé râle je dis oui mais
pourquoi pas puis j'ai lu ça m'a plu et
puis je suis pas dit oui on dit oui at
any where lyon où tu as dit que c'était
pratiquement à je savais que j'avais
envie d'aller dans l'histoire et puis
voilà quoi répit
ouais j'ai envie de partir avec les
fermes puis après quand tu lis ben oui
on est tombé d'accord j'avais juste un
truc c'est que mouloud il est sur le
plateau il m'a vachement il est le
nouveau
[ __ ] tu leur mets sur le tournage
le nouveau look away il te parle pendant
que tu tournes c'est bon je te promets
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est bien le loup ce
qu'il a fait ça il est de 3 ans les
infos toutes les cinq minutes pendant
que tu poses 10 à 10 à 10
[Rires]
l'abattoir
j'ai roulé dans 6 à 7 cm en bas et
paraît qu'il ya une fan qui t'a pas
lâché d'une semelle sur le tournage qua
non c'est le premier jour moi qui sais
pas ce qu'en mai jour de tournage en est
en panne etc avec d'immenses décès le
premier film et tout que comment fait on
est en galère on a peur tu vois là ils
vont regarder leurs gardes mouloud dont
il va zy va peut-être il va nous
rassurer et lui ne paraît il disait
c'est mon premier fils moi si on est ici
et là vraiment premier jour en plus la
scène elle est ultra compliqué il a fait
exprès vata pour nous mettre dans le dur
et où la scène elle est trop compliqué
et tout et on y va et à un moment donné
ça y est on est prêt et des actions la
haine des médias
non mais on pense que c'est palier on va
la voir on est un peu plus tu vas
l'avoir dit non non je vous laisserai
pas tant de voix de films et aux jeux
c'est vous faites un film je vous
laisserai pas faire à chaque fois que
j'entre action je vais crier non non non
c'est pas vrai des médiations
mais si c'est ça tous les jours on n'est
pas finalement donné la disparue non
parce que c'est
jim aussi mais tu t'en brouillette a
failli temps brouillé que jean claude
van damme sur un tournage est amusant
c'est que c'est un pote qui l'adorent
j'espère vous avec lui mais c'est en
fait une star d'actimel
ben je sais pas je vais aux trucs pour
bouffer et avait des actionnaires
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes vraiment bien
je sais pas je demande pas si je peux
avoir l'actuel et non c'est que pour
jean claude et tout ça
jean claude je mène patate
il est attachant pourtant été
bien
fait mais je laissais juge blanchet
cassez vous
[Applaudissements]
jean et quel est le pivot régie qui
siègent vas-y vas-y
vas-y vas-y toi m'a dit
tu as dit non il a pourtant dû à la
carcasse et où l'arrivée
c'est terminé comment je sais pas si
c'est un axe de bruitages toi tu boca et
sékou sylla jean-claude l'actuel que
pourquoi macha
vois c'est que cette histoire
découper ce qui servait à rien et du
coup bas et des sols pétanque à villars
gueule tout le monde
jim owens et d'un gros tracteurs partout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable
mais après est invité dans sa caravane
oui pour faire du vélo
notre
[Rires]
acquis mais c'est vrai que peu d traité
de fils diop sur le tournage par le
réalisateur tous les jours ça va tu vois
je voudrais bien
n'en passait pas par mouloud pas un
autre nom cité sur west c'est sur
valider des francas tandis qu'en fait
c'est j'ai l'habitude de faire des
comédies ouais ouais c'est après la fin
de la vie que je joue un rôle un peu
sérieux quoi et en fait pour me mettre
dans le personnage parce que j'avais pas
l'habitude de versailles mais il me
disait à chaque fois avant actions à
qu'il n'oublie pas ta un fils de [ __ ]
oui
regardez même aussi l'appel concernant
ces carrés les dames c'est qu'il m'a pas
autant fils de [ __ ]
c'est pourquoi ces ménagères
ça m'a permis de rentrer dans le
personnage quoi qu'en ait ce soir tu vas
rentrer ce soir pour l'équipe de france
ou pas du tout oui
il paraît que tu t'es fait servir des
cafés tout les matins pendant plusieurs
années par une future célébrités moule
c'est quoi cette histoire qui te servir
des cafés de maui camille lellouche
ouais ça ouais ouais ouais en fait elle
me l'a rappelé quand je l'invité chez
clic moyenne tandis que celle qui te
elle m'a dit c'est moi qui servait les
cafés était un des seuls mecs gentils
dans ce restaurant jeudi parce qu'il y
avait que des mecs de touche pas à mon
poste
je trouve ça très normal quoi c'est
quand les gens travaillent on respecte
leur travail c'est tout il paraît qu'il
ait cédé très beau pour voir d'ailleurs
ah bon oui plus tard j'aimerais bien les
récupérer maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]